demands national sport of sumo conjures
up visions of very large loincloth clad
men clashing into one another but lately
a new breed of sumo wrestler is stepping
into the ring lucy craft got a
first-hand look at them when she
attended a tournament in the Western
Japanese city of Osaka at just over 50
pounds make Ogawa may not look like a
sumo wrestler but the shy 5th grader is
no pushover he said plenty of bruises
her mom said but so far no broken bones
once ridiculed Japanese females these
days are throwing their weight around
the sumo ring aside from modified attire
and separate weight classes the rules
are identical to professional sumo and
matches often just as thrilling I'm a
little nervous Mei said finally it's pro
turn in the ring but all too soon it
ends in tears these girls have been
training for a whole year to be able to
compete in this national tournament in
Osaka and the matches are over in
seconds
sometimes one second his whole new
meaning to the thrill of victory and the
agony of defeat
despite sumos reputation as a contact
sport for brawling the heinous coaches
say it's the ideal workout for just
about anyone hit the head contact Irish
native John gunning learned that
firsthand
the Tokyo based sports rider is a former
amateur sumo wrestler Samoa good
exercise but it's also the most painful
thing you can do you know I mean I did a
lot of sports over my years and nothing
comes close to sumo the reigning
lightweight Queen is 26 year old Michael
yamandakka yamandakka has perfected the
ferocious initial charge Connie Hayaku I
focus on crouching as low as possible
charging and fast as hard as I can
after that I just leave it up to my
training and don't think about anything
women's sumo gained visibility with a
recent film witness sumo documenting the
struggles of females to gain respect in
an ancient sport
yet despite their rising profiles and
achievements females are still barred
from competing in sumos Mecca the Coco
geek on arena in Tokyo which President
Trump visited this year
Coco geek on has a magic all its own
even the lighting is special all women's
sumo wrestlers take pride in Japan's
national sport and want to compete there
while many support opening arenas to
female wrestlers Pro women's division
seems like a pipe dream row sumo with
its Spartan training and Shinto rituals
is less sport than a kind of quasi
religious practice it's more akin to as
I also joining the military or combined
with being in a monastery so it's a
24-hour lifestyle without the big arenas
TV exposure and lavish budget Pro sumo
women's amateur sumo remains at reading
each of the sports universe battling for
fans followers and fame for CBS this
morning Saturday
Lucy Kraft Osaka Japan patience building
the audience and the young women who
will want to continue have you found
your new sport though no I
I like the physique of the female sumo
yeah they're like they were very strong
strong and they don't have to wear those
loin cloths well they have them but yes
underneath